[Musica]
d
nella fine degli anni 90
mi trovavo a cupertino california la
sede magica della apple computer che ero
stato richiamato dal presidente
dell'europa a presidente mondiale della
pol
la situazione della apple non era quella
di oggi c'era la necessità di trovare un
modo di fare una forte ripresa della pa
e aveva avuto molto successo in europa e
per questo mi avevano chiamato in
california ma avendo la migliore delle
decisioni possibili far rientrare steve
jobs che era stata allontanata undici
anni prima e nel 96 lo richiamiamo e
vedete che la ripresa è sotto gli occhi
di tutti
direi di più che nelle mani di tutti noi
il grande steve che ha veramente
cambiato la nostra vita proprio in quel
periodo
avendo vissuto tre anni nella silicon
valley e avendo visto la vitalità la
crescita il supporto che veniva dato ai
giovani la possibilità di credere nei
giovani anche 18 19 20 anni mi ha
ispirato chi aveva avuto la possibilità
di avere responsabilità di altissimo
livello in europa in un kong in india o
creato a bangalore i primi grandi centri
di sviluppo della texas instruments poi
in america e mi sono detto una volta
finita la mia carriera voglio dedicarmi
a giovani voglio aiutarli a vedere come
realizzare i loro sogni e le loro idee
sono rientrato nel 2004 e ho voluto io
lo stesso creare una startup in quel
momento andava molto di moda le energie
rinnovabili
purtroppo dovrebbero essere state
protette più di quello che è stato fatto
creato una start up ma che mi ha dato
l'opportunità di capire le difficoltà
che i giovani incontrano quando vogliono
trovare un modo di realizzare le loro
idee
c'è veramente una emergenza giovani un
giorno ricevo una telefonata da un
giovane che mi dice dottorandi sono
loris da salerno o tanto cercato di
trovare il suo numero per poterle dire
un'idea che ho un sogno che vorrei
realizzare ma mi dicono sono troppo
giovane quindici anni non potrei mai
riuscire a realizzare quello che ho in
testa e non riesco a trovare un supporto
mi aiuti lei lei ha un network mi aiuti
anche con un supporto finanziario
mi sono dedicato a lui come a tanti
altri
ma il problema non è solo di loris si
calcola che ogni anno dall'italia
partano oltre 200mila giovani tra i
migliori perché vanno a cercare sistemi
che li possano aiutare nello sviluppare
le loro idee e tutto questo crea un
impoverimento del sistema italia
un sistema che purtroppo non ha ancora
la cultura di poter aiutare questi
giovani c'è ancora una grossa mancanza e
lo si vede nei risultati tra la silicon
valley è quello che noi abbiamo in
italia
e c'è di peggio non solo questi giovani
partono ma c'è una guerra per
vincere talenti italiani tra i famosi
bat e i famosi ga fans
chi sono i gaughran di gravame sono i
giganti del web californiani o americani
google apple facebook amazon microsoft
giganti che stanno dominando il mondo ma
nel contempo si sta svegliando la cina
circa dieci anni fa si pensava la cina
un centro di produzione a basso costo
copiavano non c'è l'innovazione è
portate oggi si sono dedicati attraverso
l'intelligenza artificiale a dei
programmi che stanno trasformando la
cina è di butt
sono questi baidu alibaba teng sen
ciao mi giganti che stanno anche loro
arrivando pro parlato di giganti
americani giganti cinesi e l'europa e
l'italia non ce n'è uno
ma nemmeno a livello europeo perché agli
inizi degli anni 90 prima di andare in
california
ero basata a bruxelles e mi avevano fa
ero presidente della texas instruments
europa e mi avevano anche nominato
chairman odia ma riganelli tronic
association una lobby di 360 mila posti
di lavoro europei
quindi aveva una posizione da cui potevo
veramente capire quello che stava
succedendo nel mondo americano
l'impoverimento del mondo europeo e
andava la commissione europea parlavo
con i membri
cercavo di far capire l'urgenza di fare
delle aggregazioni europee in cui ci
fosse più forza finanziaria più
innovazione perché si no i giganti della
bici
sto mangiando ma sapete cosa mi dicevano
il ministro dell'economia francese mi
diceva ma la bulla noi saremo i campioni
mondiali quello inglese all asl quello
tedesco l'unic source e quello italiano
la olivetti ed è vero oliveti era un
eccellenza era la apple di oggi ma avete
conoscenza di ognuno di questi quattro
hanno conquistato l'europa hanno
conquistato il mondo no sono morti sono
spariti perché è mancata quella capacità
di innovazione quell'aggregazione che
gli dava la possibilità finanziaria di
essere forti nel mondo del city e c'è di
peggio
guardate oggi la situazione economica
mondiale la pandemia ha messo in
ginocchio l'economia particolarmente
europea e ma fortunatamente anche quella
italiana ma questa pandemia ha creato
problemi per tutti
non direi due cifre nel secondo
trimestre di quest'anno 2020
se guardiamo i profitti fatti dai
giganti del web 35 miliardi solo nel
secondo trimestre
e non è finita la loro capitalizzazione
in borsa è aumentata di un trilione di
dollari mille miliardi
voi comprendete le risorse finanziarie
di cui questi saranno capaci di avere e
che dà la possibilità di questo momento
siamo noi siamo noi con i nostri dati
perché
si basano tutti su intelligenza
artificiale ma utilizzando soprattutto i
nostri dati e l'europa purtroppo si
trova schiacciata tra i boss e il gas
non riesce a comprendere che questa
innovazione tecnologica impetuosa la sta
rendendo una colonia
vogliamo diventare una colonia
vogliamo che i nostri figli i nostri
nipoti i talenti di cui noi abbiamo
continuino ad a dover emigrare
allora che cosa si può fare
io con altri abbiamo avuto un'idea con
amici abbiamo creato l'istituto europa
intelligenza artificiale e andiamo
dappertutto con grandi conferenze per
far capire al grande pubblico
l'importanza di queste nuove tecnologie
particolarmente dell'intelligenza
artificiale perché cambierà il nostro
modo di vita cambierà tutto quello che
facciamo nel lavoro nella nella salute
nell'agricoltura nel modo con cui
viaggeremo comunicheremo e quindi
cerchiamo di far capire che c'è bisogno
oggi di un piano europeo per
l'intelligenza artificiale
un modo in cui i grandi centri di
ricerca che ce ne sono tanti in europa
le università le aziende le start up si
mettano insieme facciano sistema perché
credetemi non sarà nella francia un divo
l'italia ne è la grande germania che
saranno capaci di poter essere al
livello dei gas e dei bar
quindi diamo l'opportunità ai nostri
giovani di poter veramente avere quell
ecosistema che li possa permettere di
innovare in italia e di andare
all'estero a vendere così come sta
facendo quello ris
di salerno dopo la chiamata
pensate che ha imparato la
programmazione da se stesso
quindici anni lo fate venire alla questi
tra la compagnia il cui io sono
presidente a siena lo abbiamo immesso
nell'intelligenza artificiale
il 24 luglio ha lanciato questo magni
questa magnifica piattaforma un social
network musicale che se fosse in
california avrebbe avuto di già miliardi
di investimenti per ha cominciato già ad
avere successo
30 mila nuovi iscritti che stanno
cominciando ad utilizzare questo ecco
quindi un piano europeo è l'idea che vi
lancio l'idea che cerchiamo di far
portare in tutto quanto la nostra europa
e lo dobbiamo non solo ai giovani
lo dobbiamo a noi stessi se non vogliamo
diventare una colonia ma soprattutto se
non vogliamo perdere la nostra sovranità
digitale grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]